And with regards with regards to the
universities,
I thought at one point that the best
thing to do would be to cut their
funding by 25 percent,
let them fight amongst themselves for
the remnants because it would force the
universities to decide exactly what's
important and what isn't.
So I would say the humanities and much
of the social sciences have has turned
into a postmodern Neil Marxist
playground for radicals.
The scholarship is terrible.
Eighty percent of humanities papers
aren't cited once,
once.
And so what that means is that they
write papers for each other and they
sell them to libraries and that's how
the publishers make their money and no
one reads them.
But the publishers can print them
because the libraries have to buy them
and they're buying them with your tax
money.
And so all of you who are sitting here
are funding and postmodern radical neo
Marxist agenda that has its roots in the
university and your tax money is going
towards that.
And if you want proof of that,
you just go online and look at the
websites,
especially of of disciplines like
women's studies,
which has pathological right to the
core,
but it's not just women's studies,
it's all the ethnic studies group
you.
It's anthropology,
it's sociology,
it's social work,
and most of all it's education and
noisy.
For example,
in Ontario is perhaps a part from the
Ontario Human Rights Commission,
the most dangerous institution in
Canada.
Thank you.
It should
be defunded.
It's as simple as that.
They don't do the research they purport
to do.
They're not interested in it at all.
In education.
They're interested in the indoctrination
of people as young as they can fund a as
young as they can get their hands on,
so to speak.
Now we need to figure out,
our society needs to figure out how to
stop shunting public tax money to
radical left wing activists.
If we were doing that for radical right
wing activists,
there would be an absolute storm,
but it's happened incrementally since
the 19 sixties and it needs to stop.